hillary duff reacts to her first ever et  interview i'm gonna sound like a mouse  oh cheers  it's not hard at all i mean i love doing  it the people on the set here are are  very nice and wonderful people who are  sure  follow your dreams you know  what were your dreams you know  who's that little snaggletooth rat  that is amazing what would you tell  about hillary  oh my god i guess i would be like you're  not going to believe this like ride  you're not going to believe what's going  to happen it kind of makes me want to  cry really it makes me emotional yeah  the days go by so fast the years have  gone by so fast i have done a lot and  when i see like that little girl i still  obviously have her inside somewhere you  know so